[Music]
tell me a little secret about this
amazing dress like something that people
at home looking at you might not know
something like getting ready or not I am
taped in your like hashtag fitness goals
for everybody on the planet how do you
stay so motivated you know I do whatever
I can to make time for it look Isaiah
goes down for a nap and I've been in my
workout clothes all day long and I'm
just I'm there I'm ready I make it
happen if it's 15 minutes sounds good if
it's an hour that's great it just
happens when and how it happened now
listen we love that you you tease the
boxing themed video with Keith what more
can you tell us about it's a dancing
song and I feel like that comes through
in the video you guys do get all are you
clearly do how about any double date
plan do you owe you you guys in no I
invited them to hockey game so I was
like you guys should come my America
show dates are few and far between at
this at this point in our lives just
because this season so crazy but I know
they've come to games before so
hopefully I can get them out you know
what this awesome where's the family
think about like you know this cuz a lot
of this isn't really what we consider
normal you don't like beyond normal it's
extraordinary right we honestly don't
even talk about it that much I came home
and it was like a week after the grammys
and my husband's like you want to grab
me and I was like are you sure that
should be filled in me I don't want
anybody to think a lot it's such a huge
amazing honor but it's I don't know
where we're at home we talk about our
kid and we talk about school we talked
about like groceries you know hi
you